let's start with how the head of Bill's
Mafia that's what the fans call
themselves uh went to bed last night
this is what he tweeted Dell read wrote
I hate the reason but man I love seeing
this city come together it's just what
we do you're special Buffalo
bring healing and restoration to demar's
body right now with heads bowed and eyes
closed fans and members of the Buffalo
Bills Community gathered outside
Highmark Stadium to pray for Damar
Hamlin we all feel and hurt when one of
us gets hurt a player comes to Buffalo
well they're not just playing here they
are community and they're our family it
is a sentiment shared across the Sports
World I just wanted to send my
condolences to Mr Hamlin or the Buffalo
Bills the NFL has United around Hamlin
too all 32 teams posted this on Twitter
pray for Demar the bills Rivals the New
England Patriots paid tribute to
lighting up their Stadium Jumbotron to
an empty stadium in the bills blue and
red colors and with this message Patriot
Nation stands with Demar Hamlin
Buffalo's other sports team the Sabers
arrived in Washington for a hockey game
against the Capitals players wore shirts
in honor of their fellow athlete and the
hosts even held a pregame moment of
silence Hamlin's injury undoubtedly
shook everyone who saw it but what about
those on the field who watched in agony
as their teammate collapsed and then
laid there as medical staff raced to
save his life we are all devastated like
uh when things like this happen uh it's
a it's a shock to to all of us Dion
Dawkins was on the field that night this
was uh one of the first experiences for
myself or something like this has
happened in this type of way where it
silenced an entire Stadium like that was
at a at an uproar he has represented all
of us tremendously well Terry Totten
coached Hamlin in high school he
described him as a compassionate leader
and a mentor to young players tremendous
football ability belies the fact that
he's a very good person meanwhile for
the fans back in Buffalo it's about a
lot more than football when you see
something like that happen it's just it
feels like it's in some ways uh
happening to a member of your family you
see the physical pain that Demar Hamlin
went through you see the emotional pain
that his teammates went through it
breaks your heart
here's something to make you smile Demar
Hamlin has a charity a GoFundMe page and
it was set up to benefit the area where
he grew up he was hoping to get about 2
500 you know how much they have this
morning
six million plus